I love that he's one of the most one of
the most powerful celestial beings in
the history of the world yeah and she's
like he's really sensitive you guys he
just needs a hug
I have a lot of questions about Ella's
journey this season
boy okay how do you feel about the
journey that she's going on so I've had
a blast yeah how many people can say
that they got to kiss girls kiss boys
defuse bombs on ecstasy show up to work
hungover get naked yeah [ __ ] it loose
it's been really fun because she had a
crisis of faith
last year mm-hmm which means that
anything goes and our sweet little nerdy
Ella became a bit of a wild card and now
I think it's more instead of crisis of
faith crisis of self tougher than you'd
imagine it's gonna be really interesting
because I think one of the things I love
about Ella is she's unapologetic about
who she is she's the smartest person in
the room super nerdy loves to read never
has a love interest never has a
boyfriend is in her own lane and knows
exactly who she is and her moral compass
is really strong and then if you start
rattling that what does that mean what
does that mean because she did share a
kiss last season she did are we gonna
see some romance for her this season how
would you define romance
maybe uh like things with her and Dan um
well I don't know if it'll be with her
and Dan I think that was just two people
really lost no they shouldn't
cool cool so maybe a love interest but
probably not dan yeah you're gonna see a
side of her that I think a lot of girls
can relate to you know how like
sometimes you think with you're not sane
logical mind when you pick guys today
hmm we may see some of that so she picks
the wrong person perhaps maybe HAP's
possibly hey we all got our quirks your
name mine is that I'm like actually the
devil you sort of brought this up
earlier her crisis of faith yes do you
think it's time that she find out that
Lucifer is actually uh you know people
asked me that a lot and I love that she
doesn't know because she can say things
like oh that's right you're the devil
aka are you a method actor and so I
don't want to take that fun away from
her especially now that Chloe knows I
love when he's like you know my dad God
and Ella can be like oh right your dad
God I just think it's so fun that she
could rib him as just being an
unemployed actor that can't catch a
break it needs a hug and is like this
really sensitive guy so I love that he's
one of the most powerful celestial
beings in the history of the world yeah
and she's like he's really sensitive you
guys he just needs a hug bring it in I
don't want to take away her little
sister older brother dynamic uh-huh
because I think that there's no sexual
tension there right with Ella and
Lucifer and I love that and I feel like
it's because she just thinks he's a
down-on-his-luck actor and I think if
she ever did find out because she's such
a woman of faith and if you believe in
God you have to believe in the devil and
if you believe in good you have to
believe in evil I think she would hug
him and I think she would just have a
lot of questions and I think she would
ask him they could just go out for a
beer and and really clarify some stuff
for her you got a happy right it's so
funny to say that because I was gonna
ask you how that would affect her faith
you know Ella what I love about her is
she is like a real-life angel she's not
judgmental
she gives people the benefit of the
doubt she sees the best in people and so
I think in the same way she would be
consistent like that even with the devil
because as we've heard her say before
the devil was a fallen angel and she
specifically said if you were ever an
angel even a fallen angel
means that you can't possibly be all bad
because she was an angel and so I think
that she would be really consistent with
that and just have a lot of questions
you know like who's down there is Adolf
Hitler down there obviously like you
know what you know is Prince Prince is
definitely not done you know I think she
would just ask a lot of fun questions
yeah
and besides I think the devil gets a bad
rap oh you do do you sure I mean what do
you really do that was so bad what
rebellious is dad as some naked lady
wanted an apple he's still my heart do
go on as we do wrap up this show I mean
there's only what a few more episodes
for you guys to film how are you feeling
emotionally I mean how is it coming to
work every day knowing that the end is
in sight
oh you know it's bittersweet anyone
who's followed us on social media knows
how close we are
we really are family we were a total
underdog story I mean we were a
crime-solving double show that got
cancelled and then 8.5 million people
around the world champion to bring us
back and now we're the number one show
in the world take that [ __ ] anyone
who's anyone has felt like an underdog
everyone has felt like augmenta
invisible not seen and I think even
though our shows ironically about the
devil it's really about love and if the
devil can be forgiven then anyone can be
forgiven and if the devil's got daddy
issues it's or like family issues it's
such universal concepts but at least we
got one season left and I think it's
gonna be our best one yet good luck you
got this you know how it ends
I dunno it how it ends I can't look
first of all this one is the most
stunning eyes okay you just like look at
her eyes and you like Paulo you're too
nice rabbit hole of so her and Lucifer I
think could have a mojo documented
forever it's true but I do know how it
ends and I will be totally honest when
they told me how it ends I may have
gotten a little bit emotional and then
the first thing I did was just touch my
heart Wow
so I think you guys are gonna hopefully
have the same response I'm sure there
will be a lot of Kleenexes yeah
especially cuz anyone who's a hopeless
romantic out there you know we have a
very beauty in the beasts love story
going on you're gonna cry your little
eyes out and we're gonna rip out your
hearts and we're gonna make you laugh
and it'll be fun season five we're gonna
go out with a bang a whammo well done
miss Lopez
[Music]